[Music]
my Air Jordans cost a hundred with tax
my suede starters jacket says Raiders on
the back I'm styling smiling and looking
real mean cuz it ain't about being heard
just being seen my leather deters
baseball cap matches my fake Gucci
backpack
ain't nobody looks as good as me but
this course money is show ain't free and
I gots no job no money at all but it's
easy to steal all this from the mall
parents say I shouldn't but I knows I
should got to do what I can to make sure
I look good and the reason I have to
look real good were to tell you the
truth man
I don't know why guess it makes me feel
special inside when I'm wearing fresh
gear I don't have to hide and I really
must get some new gear sooner my ego
will pop like a 10-cent balloon but
Security's tried it all the shops every
day there are more and more cops my crew
is laughing at me because I'm wearing
old gear school's almost over
summers near and I'm sworn to on Jordans
it needs something new only one thing
left to do cut school Friday catch the
subway downtown
check out my victims hanging around
maybe I'll get lucky and find easy prey
gotta get some new gear there's no other
way I'm ready and willing I'm packing my
gun this is serious business
this ain't no fun and I can't have my
posse laughing at me I'm a cop so don't
just wait you see come out of the
station West fort near the park
brother's shooting hoops and some
remarks hey Holmes when you get the
night I said to myself yeah I like this
in my life they were q-tip white bright
and blinding my eyes the red Elmen love
michael looked as if it could fly not
one spot of dirt the arrows were brand
new had my piss wound with just what to
do waiter the to was just the right time
followed him very closely behind he made
a left turn on house and I pulled down
my gun and I said get me there Jordan
and the punk tried to run to go faster
to get far five pound fool fell between
two parked cars he was coughing crying
blood spilled
the street and I snatched him at Jordans
off of his feet while and dad died all
he could say was please Matt don't take
my Air Jordans away you think he'd be
worried about staying alive as I took
off with his sneakers there was tears in
his eyes very next day I popped into
school with my brand-new Air Jordans man
I was cool I killed to get him but hey I
don't care cuz now I needs a new jacket
to wear thing
for the last 15 years that I have been
performing all I ever wanted to do was
transcend poetry to the world see it
wasn't enough for me to write a book it
wasn't enough for me to join a slam
competition and while those things hold
wait it wasn't the driving force that
pushes the pen to the pad the hunger and
thirst was and still remains how do I
get people who hate poetry to love me
because I'm an extension of my work and
if they love me that they would love my
work and if they love my work then they
would love poetry and if they love
poetry then I would have done my job
which is to transcend into the world and
in 1996 I found the answer in principles
Anna masters spoken word artist named
Reggie Gaines who wrote the famous poem
please don't take my Air Jordans and I
followed this guy everywhere
until I had him in the room and I read
him one of my pieces and you know what
he told me you're wack you know what the
problem is with you homie you don't read
other people's poetry and you don't got
any subordination for verbal measures to
tonal consideration
now he kept on rambling about poetry and
styles and Nuyorican Friday nights now I
could have quit I should have quit I
mean I thought poetry was just
self-expression I didn't know you
actually have to have creative control
so instead of quitting I followed him
everywhere when he was writing a
Broadway show I would be outside of the
door I would wake up up and it's like
6:30 in the morning to ask him who is
the best poet I remember I remember
eating the eyes of a fish but out to sea
because he told me it was brain food
then one day I told him Reggie what is
subordination for verbal measures to
tonal consideration and he handed me a
black and white printed out thesis on a
poet named Etheridge Knight and the oral
nature of poetry and from that point
Reggie stopped becoming the best to me
because what ever each night taught me
was that I can make my words sound like
music even my small ones the mono
syllables the ifs ands buts what the
gangster in my slang call for right on
the air and from that on I started
chasing after each night I wanted to
know which poet he read and I landed on
a poem called shine the stoker a toast
signifying that got me on the biggest
stage a poet could ever be Broadway baby
and from that point I learned how to
pull the microwave and attack the poetry
with my body but that wasn't the biggest
lesson I ever learned the biggest lesson
I learned was many years later when I
went to Beverly Hills and I ran into a
talent agent who looked at me up and
down and said I don't look like I have
any experience to be working in this
business and I said to him listen Punk
for y'all failed actor who became an
agent
and you know why you failed as an actor
cuz people like me took your job I've
traveled all the way from Cleveland and
Essex in East New York took the local
six line up to the hookers of Hunts
Point who were in my way on my way to
master the art of space and the one to
infinite amount of man woman and child
you can fit in it only so I could push
them to the back of the wall with my
experience people have bought tickets to
my experience and use them as a
refrigerator magnets to let them know
that the revolution is near so stock up
I'm so experienced then when you went to
a privileged school to learn a
Shakespearean sonnet I was getting those
beats kicked and shoved into me I can
match the shock of The Crying Game
with the awe of a child being called an
aids victim by a bully who didn't know
that it was his father who gave it to my
mother and that's a double entendre I'm
so experienced that when you went to the
FEL school and all the rich little fairy
boys who started to sponsor a child and
they that was me but kick me out when I
was taught teaching the fairy boys how
to rob the Pats off or pay early jeans
and bring them the VI M
let me see check off pull that off
Sanford Meisner was my uncle Otto
yelling solids himself something's
always wrong when nothing's always right
method acting is nothing but a mixture
of multiple personalities believing your
own lives of reality like in high school
cool Kenny telling me he wanted to be a
cop Duke you go to Rikers Island Academy
I can make David Mamet psychoanalyze my
attack on dialogue Stanislavski be as if
be as if he were Bruce Lee kicking your
roster of talentless students up and
down Crenshaw so what you're after study
gorilla theater at the London rep let me
tell you an ancient Chinese Saturday
afternoon kung fu secret boards don't
hit back you think black entertainers
have it hard finding work in this
business I'm a suspicious mulatto which
means I'm too black to be white and too
white to be doing it right
forget the American ghetto I've cracked
stages in Soweto buried abortion babies
in potter's field and still managed to
keep a smile on my face so whatever you
curse at me so your caddy Shack go for
this go for that assistant when I walk
out that door
whatever slander you send my way your
mother
[Applause]
[Music]